In today's video, we're
building an optical illusion.
It looks like a waterfall,
but it's underwater,
and it's small enough
that you can have
it in your house.
[Music]
I'm Nate.
And I'm Calli, and today,
I'm going to teach you
how you can make
your own underwater waterfall.
What it looks
like is a waterfall,
but it's already under water.
I can show you how to do that.
So here's the basic idea.
With some supplies
from your local hardware store
and pet store,
you can use sand
and air to create
an optical illusion underwater.
The supplies that we have
here are actually available
at most local stores.
So we have got
some rigid insulation foam,
some PVC pipes,
and a PCL bend,
bamboo skewers, the Great Stuff,
an air pump, aquarium tubing.
This is what is called
an air stone,
and some sand.
Too fine of a grit,
and what you're going
to get instead
of a nice beautiful waterfall
is actually very cloudy water.
Too course of a sand,
and what you're going to end up
with is a waterfall
that just doesn't work.
So to begin with,
we're going to need
our bamboo skewers,
a really really
good box cutter knife,
and the foam,
and the glue gun,
and with that,
we can start assembling.
So not all tank pumps
are created equal.
This is a 3.5 watt.
You want a stronger pump,
even if this
doesn't seem stronger,
this is good for a 20
to 30 gallon tank.
We're using a 10 gallon tank.
We're not just using
the 2 inch piece
of rigid insulation foam just
for stability sake,
this is also
because you can carve
into it really nicely.
Makes it a lot easier
than trying to add
a 4 inch layer of expanding foam
that's going to take
a week to dry.
All right, we've got
all of our supplies.
So let's start assembling.
The first step is to measure and
cut our rigid insulation foam.
The foam is going to end
up floating a lot on water
if we just put it
in there by itself,
but the tank does have this sort
of lip along the top edge,
and so even though we're going to add
some anchors on the bottom,
we want to try and make sure
that it's pretty snug,
so it holds itself in place.
So it doesn't end
up floating up.
The back of our tank is going
to have one piece of foam
that runs aways,
and then it's going to turn
a little bit of an angle,
and we're going
to use that turn,
partly for decorative effect,
but also because we need to hide
some of the hardware behind it.
Looks like we need to go
to about 11 and 1/4 inches high,
but we are going to have some
attachment points on the bottom
that should add a little bit
of thickness to it.
So 14 by 11 and 1/4.
[Music]
So to remind you
that the piece of hardware
that we're hiding is
a one-inch piece of PVC.
It has to be able
to fit in here,
and plenty of room
to catch our waterfall
without it being seen.
This piece is the same height,
so it should fit nicely.
But now it needs to be made
to fit kind of right here.
[Music]
Our exacto knife wasn't quite
long enough for this cut.
So I'm just using a saw.
Yes, they are in place.
Yes, they're not
really going anywhere.
However, we want to carve this
up to make it look like rocks.
We want to add some expanding
foam for the same reason,
so we have more room to carve.
We need these two pieces
to never come apart.
So now, we got to
glue them together.
I'm going to break off
a few bamboo skewers,
so that everything
stays in place.
So that when we pop
this out, nothing moves.
So that we glue it
in the right position.
And then after that,
we will add our expanding foam.
This is a little
mist spray bottle.
Just has some warm water in it,
and this can help make the foam
cure just a little bit faster.
[Music]
Where the waterfall itself goes,
add a little bit more,
and the reason why is because
you want to be able to choose
how your waterfall
is going to flow.
The more foam that you have,
the more options you have
for carving it out.
And if you go
a little bit overboard,
that's fine.
This is not a hard
stuff to carve,
so we can fix that in minutes.
Fix it and post.
So think about cliffs.
Think about the way that rock
formations kind of jut out.
You've got those
little overhangs,
things like that.
Now, it's decorative.
We've got a lot of foam on here,
and even though we've added
some spray water
to try and speed up the cure time,
it's going to take quite a while
before it's ready to be carved.
So we're gonna actually let
this cure like over the weekend
before we start cutting into it.
In the meantime,
we've got some mechanical
parts we can build.
We're actually going
to build the pump itself,
so we can even show you
how that's going
to fit into place,
how it's going to work,
and even give it a test run.
L bracket...
Yes.
And we did drill a hole in this,
so that our hose connection
be threaded down into it.
Exactly.
This is going to be
what actually causes
the air flow to bring
our waterfall up in just a bit.
[Music]
It fits down,
and you don't end up
with a kink in the line.
That will cause
the air flow to stop.
When you have an L bracket,
there's about a 3/4
of an inch lip there,
and what that does is hold
the PVC piece in place.
So when you put it in,
you lose that amount of PVC.
So you want to make sure you do
that first so you get
a correct measurement.
Now, what we're going
to do is figure out exactly
how high we want this to be.
This is upside down.
Just so you know,
this is not the way it goes.
For measuring purposes only.
Yes.
Is that--
So that's the height of the top
of the pipes should--
This will be the top
of the pipe.
Now, you've got to remember
this is going to go through.
The reason we're doing this
is that the top of the pipe
will go through,
and then we're going
to have a lip,
we'll explain that later.
So now, we're going to cut
our PVC to about that point.
[Music]
Beautiful.
It's actually going
to go in the corner.
I know that seems
a little bit odd.
The reason why,
so when the water in the
underwater waterfall gathers,
it's going to come
down at an angle.
You want to make sure
it can all be caught.
Now, this will of
course be in here.
It's going to be
a little bit easier,
but gives you an idea.
You want it all to kind of
gather in this little triangle.
The point of an air stone is
that it oxygenates the water.
It makes it a little bit easier
for the fish themselves
to you know, be happy.
This air pump is designed to just,
I mean, to pump air through
the hose down into the air stone.
If we didn't have the air stone,
all of the bubbles just come out
here is pretty big bubbles,
and the goal is to actually
to get the oxygen
to dissolve into the water.
We're going to be using
are to lift the sand.
So this tube and stone will go
inside of our PVC pipe.
When it gets surrounded by sand,
the air bubbles flying
up will lift some
of that sand with it,
and then that gets
poured out the top.
But right now,
if we had this air stone inside
the PVC set on the ground,
no sand could get to it.
So we need to give
the sand an access point
into our PVC pipe.
So this actually has two pumps.
But I'm only using one.
So, is there a correct
way to couple this?
Yes.
Am I going to jerry-rig it?
[Music]
So then, it just comes down
to how close do you want
the pump to your tank.
So I like to give it
a little bit of room,
which is actually good.
That's what I've got.
So we'll do
that side about there,
and then we'll have just enough.
[Music]
Plug it.
Seems pretty sealed.
All right, let's try it.
Go and lift it up.
Let's see.
We've got a nice water flow,
that's actually decent.
See how high you can lift it up,
and still get a water flow.
Okay, so a couple inches
out of the water,
but that's fine.
This whole thing is going
to stay submerged,
and will be nice and quiet.
So now, let's see
if we can add some sand.
And now we're covered in it.
That should be enough.
So let's go and test it out.
Okay, so far so good.
[Music]
Okay.
>> Sand is falling.
>> So you can see--
Now, this is pretty cool.
You can see that even
though we've been
pumping the sand,
the water has stayed
pretty nice and clear,
and that's because we did a lot
of work to clean our sand.
I know, it's sand,
it's not going
to get not sandy.
But what we're trying to do is
remove the extra small particles
that would just float
throughout the water,
and make it really hard
to see through.
So let's take a look
at how we can clean off
our sand to get only the size
of particles that we want.
This is some
of our unwashed sand,
and you can see
that when I add water to it,
the water gets really murky.
You swirl it
around a little bit,
and the water is getting murky.
That's what we're
trying to remove.
We're going to pour all
this sand into a sieve,
and then rinse it
off with a hose.
[Music]
Now, we can see
that it's full of water,
but even if we just get
the sand swirling up a bit,
it immediately
settles back down,
and it's clear again.
That's because we've
washed all of the dirt
and silt off of the sand.
We just have the larger grains,
nothing to murk up the water.
So that's what we need to do
with our sand before running
it through our pump,
or the whole tank is just
going to go cloudy.
All right, so it's been
a least 48 hours,
and our expanding
foam is very dry.
So now, it's ready to be carved.
We're going to carve that out.
We're going to add
in our pump system,
and then we're going to make
sure everything looks nice
and decorated at all.
Next part is just making sure
that we know where the waterfall
itself is going to be,
so placement.
We kind of formed
this little ledge here,
because we know
that we want the waterfall
to come out of this area.
Then we're going
to form sort of a pool
for everything to fall into,
and then it's going to fall back
so that we have
a full circular system.
All the air and sand
will be coming up,
and getting shot
out the front,
and we don't want it shooting.
We want it falling.
So what we need to do is carve
into the foam a little bit,
and then have it slope.
So the sand hits
that sloped portion,
and just gets angled down
to our waterfall area.
We have a spot marked off here,
and we need to carve
into the foam,
and then down a little bit.
So there's going to be some
tricky angles going on here.
I think we'll probably use
the drill a little bit.
But because we don't want
to just go straight through,
we're not going to drill
like a tunnel into it.
We're just going to carve
it out a little bit,
and we now need to add
sort of like angled hole
aiming out that direction,
at about 45 degrees.
As far as the drop,
we've already got that set.
Now what we need is
we need a feedback loop.
We need to carve
like a receiving pool where all
the sand is going to land,
and flow back down
to the bottom of that pipe.
Trial and error has taught me
that the best way to do
that is actually the carve
from the back again.
We're going to start here.
We're going to make
a little mark.
We're going to carve upward,
and then once we figure out
where that's going to come up,
then we can start
aesthetically carving.
And up here, we'll open
that up as well.
We'll recess this
whole area back in,
so the waterfall has
more area to fall.
Hopefully, we'll try
and make it look like a rock.
[Music]
We've got our foam carved
out to look like rocks.
I think we're pretty
much ready to go on that.
So next step is to make
it look like rocks.
We've got some good shapes,
but we don't have good colors.
I think it's time to paint this.
So when it comes to painting
something like this,
you don't have
to break the bank.
These are of course,
just regular acrylic paint
that you can get
at any craft store.
Now, the important thing is
if you're going to be putting
something living in this tank,
you don't want foam acrylic.
That's bad.
So we have Plasti Dip.
Now, everything that I
have read online says that
if we can coat this well enough,
multiple times with Plasti Dip,
it should be safe
for aquatic animals.
Now, don't take my word for it.
I don't want to kill your fish.
So once you do this,
once you let it dry,
once everything seems
like it's working,
and you have a filtration system
running for a couple of days,
go get the water tested.
And if everything works out,
it should be all right to go.
[Music]
Here's the plan.
Acrylic paint
dries pretty quick,
but we want to speed
that process up even more.
So we're going to put
in front of fan.
This is what I use to blow
dry my hair every morning!
Takes about two seconds.
[Music]
Okay.
So we had industrial
velcro strips that you can put
on the bottom of this
to hold this in place.
However, this tank
has a lip that's going
to hold it in place.
We made this very close fitting
to the size of the tank,
which it was really difficult
for us to squish it
down into the tank.
But now that it's in there,
it's in there.
I'm quite confident we'll be
able to fill this with water.
Yeah.
Okay, so we
have got our backing,
we've got our tank.
Now, let's go ahead and actually
get the waterfall in place.
And that should fit
snug in the place.
Perfect.
We have a double hose
for this air pump.
We're going to start with one,
see if we need
more power than that.
All right, let's make
it pretty first.
Let's see if I
can even get these--
We made like a little cave.
I want to see
if I can even get
these in here now.
Oh yeah, okay.
I will never be able
to move them,
but I can get them.
Some of our larger ones,
we also painted gold,
just for pretty.
[Music]
You can kind of see
where we've got
our tube going down.
Now, we're going to go ahead,
and add the sand first,
and then we're going
to fill this with water.
See what happens.
[Music]
The water is a little
cloudy right now.
I may have forgotten to rinse
the rocks that I got.
If you were to coat this
so it was safe for a fish,
or anything like that,
and you were to put in
an actual filtration system,
that'd be gone in an hour.
We won't have any problems.
All right, so we
have assembled our tank.
We have let
the water settle,
and I added a pet.
His name is Steve.
Should we get to actually see
if this works?
Let's try it.
So you can obviously tell
when you get up close
that it is sand,
but just as a decoration
in your living room,
if somebody sees us
from across the room,
it really does look
like an underwater waterfall.
It's really cool.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you're not subscribed,
hit that bomb in the middle.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.